i don't agree that there's a race war
going on i don't agree there's a gender
war going on i don't agree that straight
people are waging war against gay people
and trying to keep them down
that's just not my experience of life
but the only gender or race war or
like sexuality war that i see is being
waged by the left
you know so i think the left have done
this quite self-consciously in many ways
man i've just been on twitter is it
possible to browse any trends
on there without it being hijacked by
k-pop and bollywood posts
i i don't know why you'd ask me i'm not
on twitter yeah i know but you
use it right you look at the trending
side i have to yeah
um to be honest with you i'm always glad
when i log into twitter and it's some
kpop nonsense that's trending instead of
jews nazis or holocaust because these
terms
trend on twitter all the time and it
just makes me think god this is an
absolute hell site
you know i i use like you know twitter
alternatives and
never do these terms ever trend
and so it's like right okay that's very
interesting and very revealing about the
mindset of the people who use various
platforms isn't it
uh another another studio another
youtube channel how's everything going
with the
seated stuff uh it's going really really
well uh really well
um everything's up and running
everything is self-sufficient uh we have
lots of subscribers
uh which essentially means sort of
patrons but pay for everything and we
work very hard
providing them with premium content
articles from academics
book club reviews that we do and uh and
and
the sort of podcast that we can't put on
youtube because we're talking about
subjects that are essentially verboten
in some ways
uh and so it's it's been a sort of real
lease of life as well
to be able to have some freedom to talk
about things in a way that
the editors at silicon valley don't
approve man that's so good what's the
name from
the name is from the odyssey uh the the
island of the lotus eaters
is the first island that odysseus and
his crew arrive at
and the the reason i like it and i've
always found it like it's always
been sat in my mind because in every
other
island and every other event that the
crew and odysseus goes
through um there's a danger there's some
kind of deep danger that underlies
either it's a very
obvious brutal one like the men getting
eaten by the cyclopses
or they get changed into animals by
cersei or whoever
and so there's there's an ill will an
evil will that underpins all of the
other islands
but on the island of the lotus eaters
there doesn't appear to be we only get
like a few paragraphs in the odyssey
and so a lot has been extrapolate
extrapolated from that that doesn't
really exist in the text
like you know but the the thing it seems
to represent in my view
is a paradigm shift and so the the
the crew he sends out to the island to
meet the island uh the the islanders
um they just don't want to return to the
ships they just decide that they like
the place they're in and that's where
they want to stay and odysseus has to
get
other crewmen to go and drag them back
to the ships which is
kind of bad news for them really because
everyone dies on odysseus's journey
apart from odysseus
so odysseus is the only one of them who
makes it back to ithaca alive
and so you can't help but think man it
probably would have been better for the
crew members if they just stayed where
they were you know
they would have been okay so look look
this is your safe space
yeah actually that's that's kind of the
way i've been looking at it like um
because
because we've got um a bit of a buffer
from the
uh vulnerability of
social media de-platforming you know
which is obviously the sort of damocles
that hangs above all our heads these
days
if we speak about anything that's
slightly unorthodox
um the the the you know the worry is x
obviously you don't want to get the
platform that would be
bad you know your reach would be
severely diminished and things like this
but
the the way that the business has been
set up
has been very i mean i guess i'd say
conservative
but i suppose a better word be prudent
uh so that if we got de-platformed off
of all
silicon valley platforms we would still
be
employed to do something by the people
who support and subscribe to us
so yeah it's it in many ways it's kind
of like um
kind of like a safe space where people
are afraid of being persecuted
is that what we're going to see more of
do you think creators using
the existing channels as like the front
end of the funnel and then trying to get
people off that and onto an owned
platform as quickly as possible i see a
lot of people talking about building up
newsletters and mailing lists now for
that same reason
it seems it seems to be inevitable
doesn't it it seems to me there's no
particular choice
because if silicon valley is subject to
nothing but
its own arbitrary whims and their
arbitrary whims are if you misgender
someone we're gonna delete your twitter
account we're going to
if you say the wrong thing about covid
or the us election
or something like that we're going to
delete your youtube account
it becomes obvious that it's necessary
for people to take steps to protect
themselves
and i mean like i i've i got banned from
twitter for
swear words uh insults against i was
arguing with nazis in 2017
and i got banned because i was uh too
offensive to the nazis
which fair enough you know that's not
part of like the de-platforming
uh operation um and so i don't
regard my ban from twitter as part of
like the
political de-platforming although maybe
there was a political aspect to it
because
i'm not a leftist you know if i was a
leftist maybe i've been given some grace
or something
but i don't know so i won't assume but
um and so i i haven't actually been
de-platformed from anything really i'm
still on facebook i'm still on youtube
still on
you know all of the other silicon valley
platforms um
but if they can de-platform the current
sitting president
in a you know in only a few days and
just mercilessly delete all of his
accounts
um i don't think anyone should take any
risks uh even though like i said i don't
think i'm that
risky or extreme or anything like that i
mean you know i'm a democrat or i'm for
democracy i'm for incrementalism like
you know
an evolutionary sort of political
perspective i'm not a revolutionary i
don't want to burn things down
i don't want civil wars i don't want any
of these things and so i don't think i'm
very spicy politically i think i'm kind
of a
liberal centrist in many ways in most
yeah basically yeah that's actually the
the curry i choose when i'm in india as
well
because i'm i'm quite mild but um but i
do oppose political correctness and
that can get you in trouble so you've
got to make your preparations as best as
you can make them i think
did you see that stephen crowd is suing
facebook have you seen this
i heard about it but i haven't looked
into it uh could you tell me yeah yeah
so he's got that what's it called asian
lawyer john or something
um unfair company yeah half asian lawyer
john i've just misraced him there uh
unfair competition fraud false
advertising and anti-trust so apparently
they removed crowder's election stream
which is the biggest independent
election stream ever and he's saying
that they've been throttling his reach
even though facebook told the press and
congress that they don't do that anymore
hmm that's big man well that is huge
yeah and uh if
if anyone's in a position to actually
leverage
facebook and social media in this way
it's crowder and
i i saw his uh comeback video uh which
was
excellent really really high quality
production for
a guy who runs a youtube channel with
his team i was like wow that's actually
amazing
um but yeah no i'm i'm glad that um sort
of counterweights
like stephen crowder exist uh i don't
agree with everything he says obviously
but then who agrees with
everything anyone says i don't even
agree with anything i say you know so
i'll look back a year or two but in the
past and be like i was an idiot
you know i didn't understand that at all
what was i doing but uh but i'm glad
that the the sort of plurality of
opinions in the marketplace
still sustains people like stephen
crowder you know because i think it's
necessary and healthy does anyone
believe that tech platforms are
impartial anymore
i don't see how you could i don't think
they make any pretense to impartiality
anymore either
especially when the partiality is baked
into the terms and conditions
twitter being the best example of you
can't misgender someone it's like
sorry there is only one ideology
probably in all of human history that
has made a big deal about gender
identity and
uh you know gender expression in the way
that
the the left is now we all know what
ideology is in sexuality
and it's very obvious that this is uh
therefore an intersectional domain if
you can actually lose your account i
mean like i've had friends who have been
suspended for calling people dude
which i consider to be a fairly
gender-neutral
you know in an informal gender-neutral
way of referring to a person
and it's it's also um sort of part of
a how to describe it like a sort of
informal social pattern of behavior
where you
if you call someone dude you realize
that you're setting the context for the
interaction
it's like you know if i say hey mate you
know i don't expect you to call me sir
i'll be formal or say you know mister
this or whatever
and you you realize that we're having a
friendly conversation that has good will
behind it you know
it implies a kind of good will when i
enter into the conversation
and so like if in in
in my world in the in the social spheres
i exist in
um calling someone dude isn't me saying
you're a man
whereas in the sort of i guess san
francisco californian left wing view of
things
actually oh my goodness you've just
misgendered this is a high crime against
twitter's terms of service you must be
banned it's always the worst possible
implication
like the worst possible way the
interpretation
there definitely is an element of that
um but i
i also think there's a kind of dogmatic
view of certain words like um
the f word right that we can't say
anymore
uh now i i grew up watching south park
and from watching south park i actually
had not connected
really that word to homosexuality i
connected that word to
a kind of um insufferable childish
behavior which is not in my opinion
limited to people who are gay
and so i didn't consider it to be a
particularly bad word
but it's now been i guess reclaimed by
the lgbt
lobby the sort of activist lobby and
stigmatized
so now that word is actually a very bad
word that's
the equivalent of like the n word and
things like this oh god now we've we've
actually
you know from a word being actually
relatively benign and
you know not trivial has become
something again you can get banned or
suspended for from these platforms
it's like wow that's that's interesting
weaponizing words that had otherwise
lost their power
i would have thought was the opposite of
the direction that the progressives
would want to go in
but i suppose it does give them a useful
tool with which to sort of brow beat and
harry the uh the wrong thinkers so
i've been trying to think about why
social media always seems to throttle
people like steven crowder like right
instead of left
and i get it that like in the eyes of
big corporations that the left-wing's
associated with
compassion and virtue and the rights
associated with intolerance and bigotry
uh even if that may sometimes seem like
it's actually being flipped on its head
but i can't work out if that explains it
all like is there
an element that because conservatives
especially in america they tend to play
quite fast and loose with claims
in a way which is more easily disputed
so the crazier claims of the left
seem to be more esoteric and
unfalsifiable whereas the crazier claims
of the right seem to be at least rooted
in reality
even if they're unhinged do we can we
can we think of an example of each of
those just so uh so when we're talking
about
semantic overload when people are
playing around with what words mean
with all lives matter versus black lives
matter for instance
um but for people on the right
if it would be to do with um
perhaps the way that uh
workers are being moved out of jobs
about stats to do with immigration
they may be inflated and they may be
wrongly sighted
but at least they're falsifiable yes
um okay yeah the yeah the one so the way
the the way that i think about it um and
from the way you've just laid that out
um is the fact that the left
the academic left at the moment seems to
be essentially rooted
in semantics games uh the redefinition
of words in fact
and the rights in my experience and i'm
not saying this is exclusive or anything
actually tends to just use the common
english language definitions of words
and this is this is why it's actually
quite a pleasure to read someone like
thomas
sowell right because he just lays out
he never has to redefine a word because
he just uses it in the common english
parlance
because he's not trying to be a
pretentious academic about it he's
trying to just lay out look this is the
data
this is my interpretation of said data
in a common sense straightforward manner
uh do you find this persuasive and it
turns out that actually millions of
people find this
find this persuasive whereas the left
have to come up with very as you said
esoteric
ways of looking at things and actually
well let me tell you what the real
definition of a woman is let me tell you
what the
real definition of patriarchy is let me
tell you about the real and it's what
hang on a second
you know i didn't agree to any of these
real real definite redefinitions
uh and i don't agree to the definition
you finally come out with
um the classic example being of course
the definition of a woman
for uh for a right winger i guess uh
which means essentially just
someone who isn't politicized into the
culture war
a woman in the dictionary is an adult
human female which is a good and
sensible definition it's got particular
limits it has essential characteristics
and it's not self-referential so you're
not uh going around in a circle when
you're trying to define it
so it makes sense you don't need to
actually think about that any any
further really and that's probably why
it's the basic definition
whereas the left version is a woman is
anyone who identifies as a woman
which is actually a really concerning
definition isn't it because
you realize well hang on a second hey
you haven't defined the word a woman is
anyone who identifies as
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is anyone identified as and so
you've got this recurring loop in the
definition of the word
and so the sentence is never actually
completed so we don't have a definition
there anyway
uh obviously being self-referential it
gives us no information on what a woman
actually is
other than some kind of being that
identifies as
this empty word this this word that has
yet to be given any content
um and also the weird thing about it and
i've been thinking about this a lot
because like
what the the the important thing about
definitions is also
what's excluded from the definition not
just what's included
because if you take out the term adult
from the definition woman
then what you're saying is that
non-adults
and maybe even non-humans if you take
out
the human part could identify as women
and that's really weird isn't it because
i've actually had a child come up to me
when i was doing my southwest uh
mep tour um i actually had like a 12
year old girl come up to me and say
something like i'm a woman uh you know
don't oppress me i'm
you know because i'm a feminist or
something and it was really weird
because it's like look you're actually
not a woman
you know you're a child you're not a
woman so why
has this child decided that they can
come up to me and act like they're
some sort of moral authority on the
subject of what being a woman is
says they haven't got to the stage in
life that is womanhood anyway
um and the implications of like you know
taking out
the the requirement of that being an
adult is actually
kind of worrying and probably something
that should be put back in so i mean
even even if you were going to be an
insectionalist about it you'd be like
okay
a woman is any adult who identifies as a
woman would be a perfectly acceptable
no it wouldn't be acceptable but it
would be a better step up than just
having it as
completely open you know because i mean
well it opens up the possibility if we
could somehow show that this pig
identified as a woman would we be
justified in treating it as a woman you
know
and how would we justify not treating it
as a woman you know
so it obviously i don't think that we'll
be able to show that but the
possibilities are strange and silly
and it's because we've moved away from
the essential characteristics
and uh i think that you end up in this
sort of
this kind of hollow world because there
was a a un women's
uh conference uh upon which this some
uh a disabled black speaker woman
uh lady female i mean i
i don't know how i'm supposed to
characterize her but uh she said that a
woman
is something like it was something like
shapeless and formless
and timeless and eternal it's like this
is sounding like an elder god from
cthulhu like a shapeless formless
timeless entity it's like what what the
hell is the use of the term woman
anymore you know why would anyone want
to transition to become a woman or
identify as a woman
if there's no form of shape or
definition to it what was the point of
this
yeah and so this this gives strength to
the turf argument that actually they're
trying to obliterate
the term woman and this will damage
women's rights because obviously if you
can't define what a woman is and
identify a woman from anything else
how can you have women's rights and
they've got a point so
that's a very slippery game playing
around with semantics and semantic
overload and i think that what crowder
does when he does make his arguments his
arguments are at least rooted in things
that can be falsified and that people
can complain about yes
whereas with that it's always just a
game of trying to catch this incredibly
slippery eel
and as soon as you get anywhere close to
it it changes form into
smoke and cthulhu and pisses off
that that's exactly how i feel about it
and that's that's why
unfortunately a lot of modern discourse
has come down to games of semantics
which is actually terribly tiresome if
you think about it because it doesn't
advance anything
it ends up meaning you get kind of
bogged down in incredibly pedantic
conversations but unfortunately i guess
that if this is the
the current ideological and
philosophical trend that swept the west
we've got to engage with it as it is
right honestly man only in
a world where we've managed to whatever
is reduce
global poverty by 80 percent 20 years
sooner than the world health
organization said that we were going to
would this be a thing that we can do
oddly a very luxurious position to be in
to be able to talk about that
kind of nuance when it's just to do with
language previously we'd have just been
happy with a meal
that's not for me to say that we don't
want society to continue to progress and
iterate and
further and further refine the level at
which we consider human flourishing
but man like there's a lot of big things
that
needs to be done and i don't feel like
arguing over the finer definitions of
words or
one of them you know like let's you know
colonize the solar system and then
we get round to it then um there was a
thing it was it was last year
uh talking about how mars needed to be
decolonized
so they were but we haven't even
colonized it yet
and that right there is the is the punch
line the um
they were concerned there was a
particular group decolonizing mars.org i
think or decolonizedmars.org
they were concerned that colonial
colonial structures were going to be
moved into new worlds
um and it was obviously hilarious that
we're talking about decolonizing
a pal a planet that we haven't even
colonized yet
there there was an article a few years
ago um during gamergate
from the guardian where they were
speculating that gamergate would arrive
on mars
if we didn't do something about this uh
unchecked rampant populism
and uh elon musk seems to be leading the
charge on that actually so you know
god speed um yeah i know it's ridiculous
isn't it
um the the but the thing is
and i like the way you frame right
because you've got like look there is a
big wide solar system out there hey i
mean we've got enough
on the earth that we haven't yet
essentially conquered for mankind
but we've got this massive solar system
out there and all semantic games
occupy the sort of realm of the
intellectual
right so nothing physical changes with
these semantic games
and so literally as you say we are just
hit this wall we've stopped
now we're playing these semantic games
on a level that doesn't really
change the the material reality we're on
you know because you can say anything
you like but at the end of the day
unless you take some action
unless something is accomplished then
we've traveled
zero feet you know we've traveled zero
distance
robin hansen's great filter hypothesis
do you know what this is
i am not okay so um robin hansen is
a very clever philosopher he's
postulated that the reason we don't see
aliens the answer to the fermi paradox
is potentially that there is a great
filter
a barrier that all civilizations need to
get over before they can colonize
galaxies
and it could be the uh beginning of life
it could be the presence of liquid water
it could be the it could be feminism
it could be playing semantic [ __ ]
games if the reason that we don't become
a galaxy colonising civilization is
because we were playing semantic games
we didn't deserve to yes that's correct
if feminists are preventing us from
exploring the galaxy uh we deserve it
yeah we deserve it
uh what's your opinion on the madness of
wall street vets and
wall street at the moment uh it's
it's the same the same kind of um
phenomena
as gamergate uh where you have
the the the vast collection of small
people
looking up at the giant institution and
saying well
why them and not me and then when they
start making any kind of motions
the giant institution moves to protect
its interest which means
breaking the rules and acting
arbitrarily
acting a way that nobody really expected
them to act um like robin hood ceasing
the
the buying of uh gme shares like that's
i mean that was just done purely to
protect robin hood as a company
it wasn't even to protect wall street um
because they had this vulnerability
because everything has limits i suppose
but there's obviously i think that
there's probably um
shenanigans going on behind the scenes
at this point because i think they've
realized oh my god
this is actually this is cost wall
street in total something like 70
billion dollars
and that's massive you know for a bunch
of idiots on reddit who have just spent
a few hundred bucks buying a couple of
cheapo shares
that are not really worth anything
anyway uh but it's
it's the will that's behind it that's
important isn't it it's the oppositional
will
and i think that essentially what the
i guess i will generally characterize as
the elite in
any sphere of life right it could be
politics which is why we get donald
trump
it could be gamergate and video games
which is why game you get occurred
it could be in trading and stocks which
is why it's
you know wall street bets and the game
stonks revolt
um and it i've seen many people in other
different
uh walks of life in minor ways finding
themselves
diametrically opposed to the elite class
and
the elite class essentially have to come
to the table
and admit that they have accrued more
than
is justifiable in some terms and in some
ways and this is not always money or
anything like that this is
that what what what we're talking about
really is just the
sort of abstract and almost indefinable
uh or unquantifiable uh concept of power
and influence um the the little guys
feel that they don't have
the influence they deserve and that's
probably true and the big guys
feel that the influence that they have
accrued is
being attacked and being taken from them
which is also true
but the question is is there a justified
rebalancing that can take place and i
think a consensual
conversation about how these things
could be made more
fair is definitely preferable to the
kind of
civic war that we're going to see
happening between
groups of people within the same
industries
and so far this has not been handled
well
so far it has been a kind of social war
between the various factions and they
don't end well it costs everyone lots of
money
it's lots of stress people lose things
and
it it really turns out well and it just
bodes towards
uh it's kind of a downward spiral where
these things if they're not resolved
to the general satisfaction just
continue to increase the pressure
so the next time the event is bigger and
bigger and this is why
like gamergate i would say was probably
about 50 000 people at its height
which is actually really small for the
video game industry but
when you when you you know scaling this
up to the wall street bets thing you can
tell that
there's a lot of the same people who
supported gamergate and various other
sort of
populist uprisings like trump who also
support wall street bets even though
they're not the same people
doing it and they're not interested in
that sphere of life
um but the you can see the pressures
ramping up and like the wall street bets
thing has been huge
uh their subreddit was something like
2.8 million when it started and now it's
over six million so it's like you can
see the
just the graph shoot up in the number of
people who are interested in this thing
and who want to take part
in pushing back against what they view i
think rightly
as a kind of ignorant detached and
self-interested elite class
it's not new all throughout history this
has happened it's been a common thing
and this is just the 21st century
iteration of this
and so here we are the difference is now
that you've got the ability to
coordinate
so effectively the proletariat can now
gather
on mass and they can do things instantly
and there's no matter how big the hedge
fund is we've seen here
power in numbers on the internet timed
correctly
with a little bit of manipulation of
algorithms and enough understanding
of what's going on in a lot of caffeine
like you combine those things together
and it's a subreddit like do you think
this is the sort of thing that's going
to end up with legislation being put in
long term because this can continue to
happen this
level of coordination it's it's not even
that it can continue to happen
it's that it's almost impossible to stop
correct um especially when you don't
know that it's going to happen like the
wall street bets thing i've never heard
of wall street bets until about a week
i've been following them for around
about a year they are phenomenal they
are phenomenal
they're so good but that being said
i remember looking at it when it had
700k or so
on the on the subreddit and they were
watching people lose their life savings
on apple
like one person had a legend if you want
to go back and look at the best stuff
youtube search dankest trades of wall
street bets and they did a quarterly
roundup of like the most mad [ __ ]
so these guys have been doing it for a
very long time but yeah the legislation
oh yeah no no i i i i understand they've
been doing for a while and
whatnot but it's just um when it becomes
injected into the popular consciousness
through this kind of event
you know then it suddenly uh becomes a
much bigger thing i i imagine that they
probably will
try to create some sort of legislation
against this but uh but the problem is
like okay your legislative
thing but the emotion and the impetus
behind it hasn't gone away it's like
you know if you've got a a hose that
you're piping water through
a high pressure and the the hose springs
leak and you put your finger down on it
okay but the pressure hasn't gone away
you're just artificially preventing that
pressure from exhibiting at this point
and so it bursts up again somewhere else
you've got to put another thing down
another thing that
until the entire thing will split open
because you've just got too many
uh too many points on it that you're
holding down because the the thing that
is containing the pressure isn't
suitable to contain the pressure which
is why you're getting these problems in
the first place and so what this
requires is reform
you know it's a demand for reform when
these things happen because it shows
that there's a problem with the system
and every system that's built by mankind
is going to be flawed in some way
and over time the problems that are
created by those flaws build up until
they're unacceptable and the system has
to change
this is just the the nature of human
planning
um and it would i think be wiser for
those people who currently benefit from
the system
to accept that that is a an immutable
reality of things that men build and
roll with the punches rather than uh
become authoritarian and start clamping
down and
you know legislate oh we have to protect
ourselves because then
i mean it's not even it's not even just
that hey this isn't going to work in the
long run it'll work in the short run
but it was not going to work in the long
run and it might end up quite nastily in
the long run
but um it's not just that it's it shows
that you aren't
really um accountable and it shows that
you aren't really
interested in a good faith uh society
and that's the basis of civil society
rather than
rather than any kind of like um ancient
or monarchical or oppressive society
what we have in the west is what we call
a civil society and that's a consensual
society
society into which we all enter and
agree on a certain set of rules
so we won't have designs on our
neighbors and our neighbors won't have
designs on
us and we'll be able to operate freely
and consensually through voluntary
interactions and in transactions
governed by fair laws and we can all
just get on with our lives and that
sounds really appealing doesn't it but
as soon as you get an elite class that's
like actually no you can't do these
things that we can do
we've got rules that you don't have then
it becomes right so we've got
you know an evil and ill will that
underpins this thing and then it becomes
uncomfortable because but then people
have got designs on what you have
because they don't think you have it
fairly because you don't have it fairly
you got it by having a rule for you and
a rule for them
and never the twain should meet and so
it's it creates
instability in the system and when it
gets to this point we've just got
an open public revolt that's just
essentially burning money to hurt
wall street okay you've got you've gone
wrong you've gone wrong something has
been messed up you need to come to the
table
you know get get the wall street bets
guys to just elect
you know representatives tell them look
elect like five people
that you guys can trust you know and
then send them to our headquarters we'll
sit down
we'll live stream the debate you will
live stream the negotiation so everyone
can see it's totally transparent
and we'll what do you want what do we
want and we'll try and come to a
compromise
and that way people could feel like they
won both sides could feel like they won
something
you know the wall street guys would feel
they they're not about like they've got
armed guards
at the the ball outside wall street now
it's like look if you need armed guards
for just you know a private institution
it's not working yeah exactly
you're doing something that people hate
and you should stop you know uh so but i
mean not that's not going to happen this
isn't yeah
it would be it would be so good man i
had um i had michael mallis on the show
uh he's good knee he's phenomenal yeah
and i
asked him about anarchy and kind of how
it works and what it means
and uh [ __ ] me if it doesn't explain a
lot like he was talking about
when you see the powers that be take the
gloves off
that's when you realize actually they
don't care about you they'll give you
the
semblance of a piece of cheese for every
time that you do a little trick
up until the point at which you you find
a way around
the cheese game and you manage to get
the whole wheel and then they'll come in
with a hammer and hit you over the head
and as you said just there it's not a
long-term
viable strategy if you decide to scale
this
over time trust gets erased you can in
one event erase decades of trust with
the people
or with an industry or with a community
or whatever and um
yeah man i and that that's that's bad
that's the that's where
a stable society starts becoming
unstable i mean i'm i'm not an anarchist
but
i can accept that that is a legitimate
anarchist critique
of a state and you know large-scale
systems
and it is a legitimate anarchist
critique um
and so it needs to be it needs to be
spoken about one of michael malus's
strong points i've
i've only watched a few uh live streams
like tim paul and joe rogan and things
like this
but one of the things that he's really
good at is identifying the will that
underpins
actions you know he's in you i it took
me a while to notice
that why his critiques were so incisive
and it's because he's addressing this
will that becomes self-evident when you
actually look at the actors
that are taking actions you raise yeah
this you know you don't do these things
from a position of good faith you know
you just don't do that
and uh and he's really good at
identifying that that's why i love
people
that are bothered about the individual
michael's very very concerned
about personal sovereignty and
individual agency and upward mobility
and stuff like that
but he has the broader spectrum spectrum
understanding so you can see the big
picture you can see that paradigm
but he's concerned with individual
motivations and when you realize that
all that big stuff are
aggregates of individual stuff and you
can get right to the root of it you get
you get some some really good insights
there's a something i've been thinking
about
do you think well but before we before
we go i just want to
you you're absolutely right though and i
just want to reinforce that by by
pointing out
this is why the communist critiques of
capitalism always fail right and this is
why
the modern communist critiques are
especially bad because they always
approach it with
businesses are purely about making money
and
that might be true if you were to
abstract the concept of a business
into a realm that is not connected to
people and
in this abstract realm you just look at
the interests of the institution itself
but then you realize well as you say you
know everything is actually individual
action
and so when you look at the individuals
involved you realize they have ethical
motivations they have moral goals
they are not just these like soulless
corporate lunatics and we can see this
in silicon valley you know they've
adopted a kind of ideology
that gives them a license to actually
persecute some other kinds of
ideological enemies that they've
assigned
and so now it's really not about making
money you know you can you
like um youtube with the adpocalypse and
all of these other problems
like youtube and the advertisers if they
were just concerned about money
when the wall street journal's like oh
my god pewdiepie said uh a naughty word
or made a joke
about nazis or something they'd just
shrug and go so what
so what our sales are up why do we care
you know but they didn't they're all
reacting oh no that's terrible
shut things down and you know and
advertisers pull out and it's like
these are not business interests you
know youtube lost
like under 50 70 billion something like
that they lost billions of billions of
dollars
doing this so if it was just purely
about business interests
there's no way that would have been the
case and yet here we are and you can you
know see like susan wojcicki
uh you know and listen to her in
interviews jack dorsey mark zuckerberg
they do have moral interests and so it
is wrong
for the leftists to just you know
separate those and say right never the
twain meet
because this is not true this is exactly
your point do you think that there's a
common thread between the survival of
jordan peterson when the the penguin
random house
staff threatened to walk out over his
new book and then the political staff
rebelled against ben shapiro writing
their playbook and then jk rowling's
book caused the uproar with hatchet last
year
is that lesson to learn that if you're
big enough you're immune from being
cancelled
um yes because while while um
while these businesses are not purely
based on economic motivations
they still have economic motivations uh
jk rowling i think is the best example
because she controls the rights of the
harry potter franchise
she controls uh the sort of um the way
that the franchise is represented
she controls the uh the ascent the
essential decision-making capacity and
so the buck stops with her and she makes
the money from it
um which means she can't actually be
cancelled if anyone else wants to make
any money
off harry potter so is that has she
constructed her business to be like
universal studios got to come to me when
they want to do a new theme park
and the merchandising and and she gets
to be able to sign off on
the sort of um tenor and tone of the
thing as well you know like does it fit
with the mythos
which gives her phenomenal power over
the harry potter franchise as i
understand it if i'm wrong
someone in the comments correct me but i
looked into this recently because i did
a bit of a thing a
few segments on them trying to cancel
her and
they can't cancel her because if they
cancel her
nobody gets any harry potter and
i mean probably billions of people want
harry potter you know
hundreds of millions at the very least
uh you know she's she's
probably like the most successful
british author ever so there's there's
just no cancelling her because she holds
this
point of leverage and industries die
if they don't get what she's providing
and so the the activists on twitter have
been whining
impotently and uh it's been very amusing
to watch to be honest and jk rowling for
anyone doesn't know her high crime
refers back to what we were talking
about with the definition of woman
she made the argument that woman is
adult human female and if you get rid of
that you get rid of women's rights
activism which is not wrong
and this makes her a horrible turf
do you not think that it's mad you've
got jk rowling was very much in the
zeitgeist at the time though you know
she's
current and doing stuff jordan peterson
had been in rehab for 18 months
like and yeah and people had just taken
this heritage
of him again shapiro like ben ben does
his
thing like he's out there talking about
stuff jordan had been
in russia tied to a bed trying to trying
to
sweat drugs out of his system
yeah but i think um jk rowling is just
the most obvious and easy example to pin
down right because
you can see exactly the linchpin that
when jk rowling gives up the right to
make editorial decisions about a harry
potter franchise
she's cancelled right um but it's it's
not so easy with people like john
peterson and ben shapiro
because they're they're um
their staying power is based on
something a bit more
um in intangible uh it's it's
respect and influence and sort of
gravitas and that can be manipulated
with the right disinformation campaign
absolutely which i think is why the
times
recently uh put out a lie about
him being diagnosed with schizophrenia
an attempt to discredit him as an
intellectual as in his mind is
somehow you know insecure and not not
he's not sane or something like this
this wasn't true
jordan peterson released the full
interview of the times i listened to it
he didn't say they've been diagnosed
schizophrenic how do you see i haven't
seen that yet what what's the what's the
well yeah you can actually you can
actually go to lotus.com and we've got
an article
refuting this on there because um yeah
it's just not true the
the the times has claimed that he was
diagnosed with schizophrenia he hasn't
been
uh i don't know why they're claiming
this but i can only assume that they're
making up this
outright lie in order to damage his
public prestige as an intellectual in
order to discredit him within
conservative circles
and wider the wider sort of normie
public in order to
essentially just get rid of him because
he doesn't agree with certain things
does he
man that makes me feel so uncomfortable
you know like that guy's been
through hell over the last 18 months and
you sit down to have an interview i
haven't seen the interview yet
but like it's it's on his youtube
channel it's just the audio yeah
i oh it was black black screen when i
rolled over a preview it's in my watch
later
but um yeah man that makes me so
uncomfortable
like it shouldn't be the case that
someone who's been through absolute hell
comes back and because people don't like
his ideas which
for anyone who's ever read anything that
jordan's done are not controversial
he's got hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours of him lecturing
students
available on the internet go through
like scrape out you know at least with
shapiro
um he has that web page on his site of
all of the things he's ever said which
he now
regrets or wishes that he hadn't said or
whatever which i also think is quite a
a noble thing to do that's a good idea
as well to be honest
no one ever has and there's no rogue
tweet from peterson
there's no lingering
uh sort of bodies in the cupboard for
people to get out there's just
misinterpretation that's all that they
have left
but i mean yeah i i hope that
the more situations that occur like that
where
unwarrantedly people come after
prominent public figures
that they don't succeed because there's
been a few periods
you yourself included where it has
succeeded
yeah um well yeah i mean you know you
the the point about jordan peace and
what he has been through uh as has been
the consequence of a media harassment
campaign against him
you know the reason that he fell into
this hole and frank
i mean like you know i i'm i only have
sort of a middling
fame on the internet uh and in the wider
world but
even from my middling position
i mean you can see how great the beard
is right like it wasn't this gray like
two or three years ago
um it's i'm not even joking it's really
stressful it's very stressful
when you have a lot of eyes on you and
there's a lot of pressure coming at you
and pizzan is like you know 10 times
bigger than i'll ever be
and so it's it's one of those things
that's if it's bad enough for where i am
it must have been really difficult for
him and you
like like you were saying you go and
watch your stuff you can tell that he's
a very
emotionally aware person you know and he
probably has to be to be a clinical
psychologist
so he's very emotionally connected to
things and to other people and he cares
about these things you know he's been
he's cried on live streams when thinking
about other people's suffering and stuff
like this unashamedly you know
it's very brave actually to do this i've
seen lots of leftists mocking him for
showing his feelings
well hang on a second i thought that's
what you wanted out of men you know what
are you doing you know don't
when he opens up don't stab him you know
christ but
um but yeah so for peter i can
understand why this was just too much
for him to handle
uh why he ended up falling down this
this sort of rabbit hole and
having to spend a lot of effort dragging
himself back up
and like you say you know if you watch
any of his stuff he's talking
essentially he's essentially giving you
the sort of like best
dad advice that can be given you know
get your house in order ultimately
he is but it's great advice for young
people not just young men but i think
young men need it more than young women
because there are lots of social support
structures for young women everywhere
because of feminism but young men
definitely i think need this kind of
guidance where it's like look
get your house in order sort yourself
out clean your room get on you know get
on the
the business end of actually doing
something and improving your life and
i mean you know i've i've taken his
advice to heart you know i think a lot
of other people have as well
and it really does work it's just about
taking responsibility for yourself
and if that is if that's his high crime
and that's the great offense
that jordan peterson has committed well
i guess we're all in trouble aren't we
[ __ ] as a world do you think uh trump
is gonna go away now
or is there any chance that he's gonna
run in 2024 what's your ideas around
this
i have no idea and i don't i don't dare
make any predictions
because all predictions are aging very
badly at the moment
uh i mean is that can you think of a
single person who has made a good
prediction in the last five years
morgan housel who's a financial expert
tweeted at the start of last year
saying about how much time people had
spent analyzing the
2010 until 2019 decade of trading
and extrapolating out all of the
different charts for the coronavirus to
come in and just totally sideswipe
everything that they've done
yeah that's the thing like er the
political environment is very unstable
at the moment
uh so i i don't predict but
i wouldn't be surprised if in 2024 he
runs again
i expect that he will and i think he
would be
a powerful force if he did um less
powerful
now that he's been de-platformed from
every silicon valley platform
um and that's what the silicon valley
cartel know they know that this has
reach and influence and power
so really if i were donald trump and i
were thinking about it i would choose an
alternative social media network
and make that the network that i used
and then you can get probably hundreds
of millions of people
to at least look at it occasionally uh
if not join it and actively participate
but i mean the
the social media alternatives parlor was
doing fantastically
well until they got de-platformed and
gab is also doing fantastically well and
they can't be
de-platformed because as i as i
understand that gab are
responsible for their own infrastructure
although i've been told that's not
entirely correct so i'm not sure about
the details really but uh but basically
andrew torber who runs gab has been
de-platformed in the same way that paulo
was
and so he is uh protected against that
they can't do that twice
and so trump should choose a platform
that silicon valley can't
d-platform and get to work he's got a
few years if he wants to do it he's
he can do this you know he's got the
money he's got the time he's got
uh the political capital to do it as
well
especially as the man the manga base um
generally don't feel that
this was a legitimate they think that
this was a stolen election whether you
agree with them or not
um so if trump uh starts getting back
into the action
uh i think that he'll do very well the
thing is it also might be a wise um
political move to actually
let the situation breathe for a while
right because what joe biden is doing at
the moment
makes him by his own standards kind of
looked like a dictator
uh he was the one criticizing excessive
use of executive orders and then 30 of
them
plus in his first week and it's like
okay what are you doing
you know and the radical radical changes
you know bringing
critical race theory training uh all you
know all of the changes to the military
of transgenderism and things like this
it's like
okay these are these are sweeping
changes that biden is making
and they're not good changes they're not
they're not changes that the general
public
actually endorses you know how many how
many of the general public want
frontline female soldiers
probably not that many of them you know
it's it's very much the sort of
progressive wing of their party that's
driving the agenda
and biden's just leaping you know both
feet in you know he just doesn't seem to
care
about any any objections now and so it's
like right okay let him govern badly
give him enough rope exactly give him
enough rope
so if if i mean trump waits like six
months for a year
before getting like fully engaged back
into politics
uh then he might find himself with a
very weak opposition where they've
overextended
you know they've tried to impeach him
which i don't think is going to work
because i don't think they're going to
get the votes
and so that'll be a waste of their own
political capital it'll give
people like aoc time to sort of march
around on the field of victory and
be really insufferable and put a lot of
people's backs up just by the way that
they operate and i think that's
happening
um and it will the republicans have kind
of been routed
after the capital riot uh and so they
give them time to regroup allow biden to
ruin things
and then come back in a big storm and
hopefully uh
take it but uh but again not a
prediction just the kind of fantasy of
what i think could happen
dude so one thing that malice said which
really really struck a chord with me
is people thought that trump
was the river when in fact he was the
dam
a lot of right leaning
americans felt like they were being
represented by trump
and look what happens when you take away
that dam they no longer have anybody
that's speaking for them
they no longer have anyone that they
feel is representing them so [ __ ] it
insurrection
i uh that there is definitely a strong
undercurrent of the republic is over in
a lot of the republican circles now um
which is not good
you know it's not good at the most
powerful country with the most nukes in
the world
yeah i'm not too worried about that um
but what it is
is if if america becomes consumed with
its own internal disputes then
people like china and russia are always
watching from the margins and seeking
i mean china's already been violating
taiwanese airspace and things like this
right
this is not taking long joe biden is not
going to have a firm hand with china
like trump did
uh and it will not be to the benefit of
the united states
um and you i think you i think you're
really right about the damn
thing trump really seemed to have been
holding back a lot of
uh initiatives that really seem to have
a negative
intention towards the average american
person
uh in favor of fringe activist groups
who have been making their voices very
well heard but don't represent a very
sizable constituency
even necessarily of the minorities they
claim to represent
like for example feminists like very few
women are actually feminists
like less than 10 of women self-identify
as a feminist
and whereas 80 of women will say well
yeah i think there should be
equality between men and women so the
overwhelming majority agree with the
basic feminist premise
but they won't identify as feminists
because they don't want to join the
activist group
because they can see that this is the
you know the man-hating lunatics
right and so the biden is catering to
these fringe
internet activists with everything and
so like let it
you know let it go it'll it'll be
insufferable
but um you'll when when this has gone on
for enough time
hopefully someone from the republicans
who is capable and competent and decent
will come along
i've noticed that they're really going
hard on a senator called josh hawley
at the moment because he wanted to
represent his constituents concerns
about the lack of apparent transparency
and their belief in the invalidity of
the election and the electoral process
and he is being treated as if he led
some sort of armed insurrection into the
capital
which he didn't he was in there giving
his testimony when the
event occurred so the fact that they're
treating him
as if he was leading it is very
interesting to me and he hasn't backed
down on this either
he got the platform from his book and he
hasn't backed down and so
i'm i'm thinking someone like him is
probably
if because you know trump trump's going
to be in his late 70s by 2024
and as vital as trump is as energetic as
trump is
that is old you know and it is a very
stressful job and
etc but josh hawley looks like he's in
his 40s
um the right kind of age to start
pushing forward with this kind of if if
i mean he might not be that very
inclined he might be a wall street
guy you know he might have been bought
off he might not be a populist in any
way but that's not the impression i've
got from him actually he seems to be
interested in representing the sort of
rural working class and the rural
interests um
and someone like that is definitely
necessary
for the american political system if it
wants to survive i think
i think if one side is just not
represented and one of the things you
notice about the democrats is they are
going
hard on their republican opponents they
are they are trying to extirpate them as
much as possible
and that's the exact wrong maneuver to
take if you think you're a legitimate
winner
you don't want to punish the opposition
for losing you know that's not what a
democratic system is meant to be
but instead they're acting like they
didn't win
you know they're acting like they've
done something wrong they're acting like
they've got guilty consciences
and uh and yeah i don't think it's
sustainable i think they'll overreach
one of the things i've noticed is a
change in the attitude towards
american national pride i can't tell if
this is actually happening at a cultural
level because all my information around
gets
filtered through their major obviously
yeah but it definitely seems to be a lot
less about like the star-spangled banner
and pledging allegiance than it used to
be
is someone killing american national
pride oh absolutely it's the left and
it's been a coordinated effort for at
least the last two decades
and honestly i i remember back in about
2001 in fact
that i was kind of a part of it without
knowing it um
when when the twin towers had been uh
blown up crashed planes into collapsed
um
there was this distinct feeling
that this was unacceptable american
nationalism when george bush was there
on the ruins with an american flag and
people chanting usa right there was
there was a distinct feeling
uh on the left that this was scary and
this was going to lead to fascism this
was going to be
and don't wrong i don't approve of any
of the consequences of
911 or 911 itself i didn't support the
invasion of
iraq or anything like that um and there
there were obviously terrible
consequences from that
but um but i think this has been that
was the flash point that started the
left on
a sort of conscious attempt to undermine
american patriotism
and and i think that that has been
successful
i think that much of the left now openly
admit that they hate america they think
it's an imperialist white supremacist
power
capitalism is inherently a racist
structure that's designed to oppress
people
and the communists who have been pushing
this view of the world
have been very very successful in
planting the seeds in the left
and destroying the patriotic left the
sort of
you know the sort of working class left
who actually like america and just want
the rich to give them a bit of the pie
uh those people have been totally
marginalized and now it's
whites versus blacks or you know
straights versus gays and all the so
now it doesn't really reflect actually
what's happening because
i don't agree that there's a race war
going on i don't agree there's a gender
war going on you know i don't agree that
straight people are waging war against
gay people
and trying to keep them down that's just
not my experience of life
and maybe i'm talking from a position of
privilege being a straight white man
but the only the only gender or race war
or like sexuality war that i see is
being waged by
the left you know so i think i think the
left have done this quite
self-consciously in many ways
i think in the uk we're already used to
kind of british national pride being
silma's seen as the realm of
racists and working-class thugs right
like hanging a flag ups the sort of
thing
that the community watch ring the
council about and you get
absolutely get people around to your
house i wonder if america will end up
like that i fear not
i don't think that they will i think
that it's too strong that patriotism
it's been very very very ingrained but
the left do
definitely seem like they're making a
good job of trying to deconstruct that
yeah i mean they're very good at playing
the long game so in
in 2001 it didn't look like there was
any possibility of demolishing american
patriotism but here we are going well
god and the americans even going to be
patriotic next year
you know so it and it's only been 20
years so
it doesn't take that long it doesn't
take that long in the grand scheme of
things
and you're right obviously over here
it's gross how unpatriotic we're allowed
to be
this is why i've got the flag behind me
i'm not naturally a flag flying guy
like this you know it's not something i
would naturally do but in the current
circumstances given the current context
oh yeah we're having a british flag
you know and uh and if we get told off
for that an english flag goes up as well
if that's what they want you know i'm
not i'm
i'm not backing down on this you know i
bought an english flag a while ago for
the first time ever and i was like okay
what do i do with it now
you know do i go and flights outside my
house is that going to be imposing on
the neighbors i don't know
but uh but i bought it just say i had it
because i'm sick of the
genuinely anti-patriotic feeling that
the left is pumping out and it's because
they're essentially communist now
socialist or communist which is
essentially a synonym
and they they view
national pride as a form of false
consciousness they view
national pride as a barrier to communism
which it is
which is why we should support and
uphold it which is why you should get a
flag
yeah fair point it is bizarre like you
go through
you go to gyms go to a crossfit gym in
in america
and you'll see hanging from the ceiling
there'll be us marine
navy core there'll be the
red white and blue star spangled banner
and there'll be like some other stuff as
well and you just think like there's
such a
at least this was three years ago might
have changed now yeah um
it just felt like there's such a
cohesive i actually got quite jealous i
had like
um country jealousy in a way where i was
like man i've never
have you ever heard anyone say i am
proud to be a british citizen
like i'm proud to be british you know
like saying the sentence
i'm proud to be british sounds like it's
something that comes out of that muslim
ray gangs
uh video from a few years two two two
two places right uh none of it neither
of them in britain
the first one the the first one not hong
kong i
and nearly uh i i grew up on a military
base in
germany uh obviously it was called joint
headquarters jhq it's near much in
gladback
or it was it's been decommissioned now
um but there
that again when you're when you're in
close contact with a foreign culture
you become very much aware of your own
culture and its strengths and weaknesses
and the virtues and vices of it
and then you become a lot more
self-reflective about the thing and so
you you it wasn't you know it wasn't
like you know chess beating nationalism
or anything
but you know that was the sort of vibe
that had him because it was a military
base you'd have
you know the flag and things like that
on flagpoles you know so it felt more
patriotic
and the other the only other place i
felt this is in gibraltar
when i went over there for the mep tour
um it was
like a a very beautiful uh british
village
that's been transplanted to the south of
spain and there were british flags
everywhere and it was lovely you know
because the weather was amazing for a
start
and everyone was really nice you know
everything was really relaxed and
friendly and there's you know british
flags everywhere and everything was very
patriotic wasn't it callum
you know calamania was great um and uh
and we had a great time there and it
just felt
very nice very relaxed and you know it
was
wholesome it was good but they're the
only two places not in britain
so bizarre man so bizarre give me your
thoughts on aoc
i know that you you like to think about
it sometimes
not really unfortunately passed into the
dialogue
she injects herself into the news yeah i
i basically view her as a kind of um
kind of like a robespierre really i
think that she's very much like russia
she's
she's a a politician or a political
actor and she's a radical a real radical
and she is uncompromising she's she does
not
consider the republicans to be moral
agents
she views them in the same way that uh
the
the hobbits view the agents of sauron
you know the the the naz girls she views
them like that
the fact that they exist is an
unfortunate necessity and the fact that
she has to deal with them
but she will attack them as viciously as
possible
at every opportunity that she gets i
mean the perfect example recently
was her saying oh maybe the wall street
traders should be not stopping people
from training on their platforms
and ted cruz said i agree and she said
you nearly got me killed
it's like you should resign it's like
okay well that's not exactly
the spirit of cooperation is it aoc uh
and now today we've got the recent uh
i i'm a survivor of sexual assault
the way that the republicans are
treating me is basically the same way
that i was treated by the person who
sexually assaulted me
therefore the republicans are basically
gaslighting rapists and it's like right
okay this is not a good faith actor this
is someone who
is here to harm you they're here to
undermine you they're here to destroy
you they
get rid of you as much as possible and
if you watch the um
the sort of speeches she gives on the
interview she gives with
friendly media people she knows her
inside the progressive club
she almost says exactly these things
she's like we've got to stop them we've
got to get rid of them they should
resign we need to
replace them we need to get rid of them
and all sort of stuff and so it's like
she's not shy about this and she is the
destructive
radical communist force that's entered
into democratic politics
and is working its way through the
social uh mechanisms of
the american body politic damaging
people who otherwise shouldn't think
that they would be damaged right the
platformings and things like this
aoc is the crest of that wave and that's
really bad this kind of bad will this
this
this ill will that travels through the
political environment
is what's going to destroy the american
republic because the american republic
fundamentally is built on the idea of a
good will
that brings together a society from
which they can constitute a government
i mean it's literally in the declaration
of independence you know and it's based
on
locke's view of government and society
in the state of nature where men come
together voluntarily
to sacrifice some of their rights in
order to provide security and protection
for their property
and that will only hold as long as
you understand that there is a good will
in society and the government isn't
going to be used to persecute you but
the government is already being used to
persecute the mega folk
who happen to hold strongly to the
lockheed view
of the american republic and so on a
subconscious level
i don't doubt that there are many
american republicans out there thinking
my god the republic is absolutely over
because they're trying to use the
government to persecute us
and this this is the incredibly
negative effect that people like aoc and
the squad are having in american
politics
and uh and don't get me wrong the right
has their own versions of this
but the right the republicans keep out
the sort of richard spencer's and nick
fuentes's of the right the the you know
the
the the belligerent and unforgiving
culture warriors that would be on the
right they don't
actually engage them you know they this
is this is why trump was such a surprise
because
he's like a halfway house between them
and the mainstream republicans you know
so in an acceptable way politically
um but yeah so i i'm i'm not very much a
fan of aoc in the way that she operates
do you think that she believes what
she's saying
because when we saw kamala harris
last year during the democratic
primaries
and she essentially accused joe biden of
being a
sexual assaulting misogynist whatever it
was
and then when asked about it said
it was just a debate bro yeah yeah so i
don't believe that
karma harris i like the fact that
someone who is such an evident sociopath
has made their way into the second
highest seat of power
in the free world is that
really scares me biden doesn't scare me
biden doesn't scare me
his um forgetfulness
worries me but he doesn't scare me
however
kamala harris really really does scare
me i'm pretty good judge of
people i've spent a lot of time looking
at people and
there is something incredibly wrong with
that woman
um i i think she's a corporate chill
i think she just uh is doing this for
her own enrichment and the enrichment of
her family and friends
but aoc i think probably is a true
believer i think that she
she knows that she's being insanely
hyperbolic when she's attacking
republicans
but i think she does on a genuine level
believe that they are bad people and
should be gotten rid of
but i hate to do this but um i allow
everyone to clock off at five and so
they're like
you know come on come on so we have to
leave it we're gonna have to leave it
all for next week
we are gonna have to that's yeah but
dude i'd love to do another one man
let's get it done it's always a pleasure
to have you on thank you for coming on
again people want to check out more of
your stuff where should they go
go to lit seats.com perfect man got lots
of stuff there
carl thank you and uh dude keep up the
gym work
such a thank you such a pleasure
watching the the weight loss journey
over the last year
thank you yeah i've been i i very
quickly i i basically
one of the reasons i set up the office
right and it's an entirely selfish
reason
is because i wanted it to be about half
an hour away from my house so i've got a
bike and i'm just every day riding half
an hour and back
to working back and yeah i'm i'm feeling
great you know i'm much more fit than
i've ever been i've got a
weight spar so i've been doing pull-ups
and stuff and yeah so i'm quite pleased
with how things are going
for for a man in his 40s i'm feeling
pretty good about it it is snowing
outside mate so if you're gonna oh is it
oh maybe in newcastle
oh yeah it's always snowing here in
winterfell isn't it anyway man safe
journey home thank you very much for
coming on
[Music]
cheers
[Music]